スクールデイズが好きですか woman
懐かし
あーちょっと
好きですめちゃくちゃドロドロしてる
アニメなのでぜひ見てみてください今日は
肇社長です今日の動画防災訓練ですという
わけでこちらの方にお越しいただいており
ますどうぞ
お願いします一応か元気ですよございます
全然でよろしくお願いしますあります
説明です先生やはり私は思ったんですよ
かじって突然起きるじゃないですか学生の
時とか避難訓練とか練習してると思うん
ですけども私のようなその社会不適合者と
言いますかぜひそのありがとうございます
社会にずっをしてないというか会社とかに
いないとするクールでところすることない
から多分今僕カちゃ起きると死ぬんですよ
もう
そっかスポッという幻覚とか通路とか何に
気をつければいいけどほぼは覚えてないの
で確かに中にね起きると頭がパニックに
なってどうやって動いたらいいかわかん
なくなりますもんね7分中央ですね
ちょっと僕も含めなんですけれども
ターゲットを読んで気づいて気にせてあの
安全に価値って怒ってますからカジノ演出
ですかねそうですねはいできますできるん
ですかちょっとそういう話を聞きしちゃう
ね演出のプロの方をねお呼びして魔王さん
今日クラウドの石川さんです違えば間違い
ます作曲ライドですかと申しますしかし
まぁ作曲ロードそうですねーフォッカー
2人とか特殊訪韓と呼ばれるものをやって
実際にそれが起こってないけど怒ってる
ように見せるっていうもののプロの会社で
もないしかも目が痛くなるくらい飛ん機の
クロいつもごなくことそれは安全なんです
橙子もらえるだけじゃないかなぁ人体に
影響がないか言わないといいですね
みんなシュヴレールが風に近いと思うので
リアルなんかするお願いですねはいそれに
僕もまだ相撲ってちゃんとたいている
ところを確認してないので僕も多分
テンパると思うんですけどあの
頑張りますからねあの想像以上に本気だし
て家事に移していきますので受かりました
耐えてください
はいちょっと塾で本気でパニックになら
ないように素描
店長へ
はいフォルダーがよこれはくださいという
キュッとしましてまぁはぁゲットを読んで
ここに座って嘘の企画をしますで知ってる
間に人か譲歩していただきましたよねはい
その中でターゲットかどう行動するのか
そうですねどこをどうやってみたらいいか
とかね基本を押さえられている動画たよ
ねーぞ情報頃それを大変なほど心地に火事
だと思ってやってもらいたいので順でも彼
てぜひ宜しくお願いますはい
でターゲットの到着を待ちましょう
軽い軽い
おりません
を得ないぞんだろう
広い広い社員だ a ロイゼ
井戸いねえぜ
ふーんそっパッヘルベルさやな久しぶり
です廃狩りの変だがいるみたいなちょっと
ちょっとかわいい感じになっちゃう
ゆりさびさに4つありましたーーー
道で始まるこのうち
側に見ましたけど
8サイトですボンブ tv ふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇ4つ以外に
文ちゃん後火ちゃん
食べちゃっちゃー今日は
女の方の撮影測定とかいますだバーで良い
散財じゃーん
まずはまだ今度付いた花粉でねはい定休
自宅前と中央
物を着て行ってきましたいや今日の客ある
ず本当に抜擢だよっちゃんだ一応ブーブの
社員さんなわけですよはいそうです僕が
所属している家務所の社員犬クリエイター
というハイ一番触りづらいポジションやっ
てるかパリーフライから今回ね4つの中に
入った時とかに領地のことどう思ってるか
本音で a
てることがたくさん聞いてきますわー
ハートは今ママジッといけませんぱい
[音楽]
ん名前を伏せたんで俺5-4
ですが分前2
何会え前の上段を訴え冗談早いよな
られる4つはございません
今日も肌嘘 t 本番なんかおりこねえよ
ご案内も何んマッハ
wh続けるぜってやってもらえ煙だけどは
携帯で道南2受賞はハーパー
ユーチューバー
year
やばいべっのん4つ道
んじゃないじゃあもう入って古来の机は
きれい1パット目指されて後声が合う
大きいやそれは
んじゃだからあそこで行っちゃ誰アレアレ
してアレは音や人や怖い怖い work
ワークプレーが出るぞ入ってくらい入って
ごらんふううううううっなんかやばそうだ
ね一方だいいでしょいや加えチャンジャー
通っては頭神経頭の神経02巻分が歌い
なぁはいじゃないほか j 翼ガチャも
大丈夫か式部いたってた沢山の時やいけれ
ばいけないけどね
いやっ
ん
火事火事火事火事火事れマジマジじゃなく
ちゃってまず
のにのにパーッが誤ってますよ
第二巻
なぜ
ちょっと目を通してねこれ俺どうしたら
いいの
これ堂社員の声
いややばいやばいと思うんじゃんだよね
えっあどうすればこれでちょっとやれ
jaja だようんこれずっだじゃないえ
なになにある
アクサ山なんで嫌だ一人じゃね
妻
やらにゃんくろ俺は俺
山へなぜ俺はぺこは今日ちょっとあ
ブーブーポリピュア
ティ
ドッグねぇ
中盤たよ
ぴょんっ
時点でおでございましたよ俺
うわやばいんです
ちょっとばずやばい考えどうしてどうし
たいのコレドシャルのこれ
どうしてもこれどこにチャンスの際分から
ない姉なにこれで月はこっつしかないから
ごっちゃこっち来ねえああヤバいってこれ
やばい
やばいうわーいヤバすべくの動線は何も
見えないんだけど
選挙なるのけ
弱いやばいやばい
やばい号いないこれですよねうさぎって
やばいとかさっきんだよじゃあ今あちこち
道具前
車で全然ないな
チェーンはいねえええ
いやんますよ
dare
ああああああ
ありません
ん
食べていますmemeカード撮影中2名
数になる ws 茶や利水ください頑張っ
て神経な賭けな
外してくれあの
をれがちだ学生時代と違って避難訓練と
隠せないだろ
砂色3ゲームしてねだろ a その2
インチ緩んでねーかなと思った
髪を意図的に起こしてああ
食べてもらうところまぁ失敗ああっ
[音楽]
npo デー俺もぜひと見てないから
2びっくりしたっくれっ
海野いっちゃんナビじゃねっ
江戸かじってまずはな感じやすいからね
いやほんとやばいにも名本当に開いた技術
だ
家事ということで早速たちの来県ツアー
行きましょうつ風のない変さあもういいへ
もういいとちなみに本当に彼はには部会に
おけるんだから本当に何かとかじゃない
ですん
ただその山どうぞとカメは来るからえっ
なぜダイブッ
俺じゃない
ほんとにねーミーハーっくらいにもう
うわー
これっないても人じゃわかんないよ
空気当館かずつは良いん
何度たいとかもう真っ暗じゃんきりみたい
であるん
過ごす下校や4日みてくださいこれ以上
ですか
これちょっとこの人へいつもなるほどれ
ですからっ今ここでどうゾンっても猫し
ません本当にでも風お母様だったやおや
分かりました方がいらっしゃいというやつ
だねっ
元気線すると知ってますよ特殊な演出の方
も協力など元気
何へ
なんでデッキ
[音楽]
はなくなって肌が黒くなってるけど花
くらいのブースター
山ナックル元からかって羽後じゃないよ
スモークにすごい映像 by するんだよ
これを五湖っこい言えばいっぱいいるぞ
いうわけではいはい無害なんですよね無害
でちょっとエロいですよな使ってパスの
園舎は相撲くださいちょっと地域あるん
ですけどまぁそれもいいっということで
ガーン激しい稽古で昔あったじゃん学生の
時ました
ないから子へ戻っているパニックになった
そのパニックなりました超ばいいかなと思
知るかった共通と同市を通し言ってました
がもうどうじゃ甘い見えないしん真っ暗
だったもんね本当に暗くなりますよねそう
ですねぇ僕までこんなに暗くなると思うの
だけどロッカー何も見えないほど真っ暗
真っ暗ヤミヤミ
うーん本当の火事に遭ったのに元どんな
報道すればいいのそれでわかったから
じゃあちょっと存在しますその以上ヨッパ
景色変わった人数の思いましたね空間とや
色ちゃーんはい我々もういつかしろって
言うかわかんないですからそうですね一語
の表記てた方がいいかなということではい
今日君にこんなドッキリを仕掛けさせて
もらいました反映ありがとうございさし
ないとだよねございましょうまあ